likely around this time to confirm that
he plans to continue with his road map
the next stage of which is due on monday
reopening
for instance allowing people to see each
other indoors in private homes
and for hospitality to open up inside in
groups of six
some venues can allow in up to a
thousand people so
possibly actually the most significant
of the various points along the road map
uh to go ahead but there's been a butt
and it's a butt that has
really descended on whitehall this week
so a bit of a chill down whitehall this
week in the form of the
indian variant you've got that tripling
of cases in the northwest
all of a sudden uh undermining the
complete confidence that the government
had
at the start of the week that uh not
only this bit of the road map but the
one that follows in june
uh would progress without too much
problem because of the extraordinary
pace of the vaccination uh regime now
suddenly you've got
a variant that is one of the one of the
variants that has come over from india
but only one of them has been designated
a variant of concern
um and the the issue really is that
talking to scientists throughout the day
uh that they just don't know a huge
amount about it it seems that
the indian variant that is currently
prevalent in the north west particularly
in areas like bolton seems to
pass through the population is more
easily transmissible
even than that kent variant that we saw
which caused so much damage so much
misery uh just before christmas
but and it's a very very big but
there has been so much progress with the
vaccination
regime that it looks as it which looks
as if it's holding up against this
indian variant without too much
uh problem scientists are scrabbling to
work out uh what the interaction is of
the new variant
coupled with uh the vaccines so boris
johnson i suspect we'll press the
green green go button on
for monday to go ahead but the following
months
uh basically complete total relaxation
uh
of the real rules uh on june the 21st i
think that
uh that will uh possibly come under more
strain
do you think he might announce something
about vaccinations for
younger people in these hot spots which
we're learning about we heard from
international inception that one
pharmacy was going it alone
so uh i think one of the things that
government are grappling with is
essentially whether or not to double
down uh with the second dose to
older people of the vaccine particularly
in areas where the indian
variant is prevalent or whether or not
that it would be a better idea
to start moving down the age ranges in
order to vaccinate younger people who
currently are exposed it's the
unvaccinated i suspect
the data certainly suggests are most at
risk
and this would be a question for
government advisors here is boris
johnson
throughout this pandemic we've tried to
keep people abreast
of the latest information as soon as we
get it and since i spoke to you
last monday we've seen further clusters
of the b1
617.2 the variant first observed
in india and we've seen it especially in
bolton in blackburn with darwin and some
other parts of the
country at this stage there are some
important
unknowns we believe this variant is more
transmissible
than the previous one in other words it
passes
more easily from person to person but we
don't know
by how much i'm told that it's only
marginally
i'm told that if it's only marginally
more transmissible
we can continue more or less as planned
but if the variant is significantly more
transmissible
we're likely to face some hard choices
and
we're going to be learning a lot more in
the coming days and weeks
about that the good news is that so far
we have no
evidence to suggest that our vaccines
will be less effective
in protecting people against severe
illness
and hospitalization so that means we're
in a different position
from the last time we faced a new
variant
before christmas because of the the
scale of our
vaccine rollout which public health
england estimates has already saved
almost 12 000 lives
and prevented over 33 000 people
from being hospitalized so i believe we
should trust in our vaccines to protect
the public
whilst monitoring the situation as it
develops
very closely because the race between
our vaccination program
and the virus may be about to become
a great deal tighter and it's more
important than ever therefore
that people get the additional
protection
of a second dose so following
advice from the joint committee on
vaccination
and immunization we will accelerate
remaining second doses
to the over 50s and those clinically
vulnerable right across the country so
there
that those doses come just eight weeks
after
the first dose and if you are in this
group the nhs
will be in touch with you we will also
prioritize first doses for anyone
eligible who has not yet come forwards
including the over 40s
and i urge anyone in those groups to
come forward
as soon as you can at this stage
there is no evidence of increased cases
translating into unmanageable pressures
on the nhs
even in bolton and infections deaths and
hospitalizations nationally remain at
their lowest levels
since last summer so
and this is a a balanced decision i do
not believe
that we need on the present evidence to
delay
our roadmap and we will proceed with our
plan
to move to step three in england from
monday
but i have to level with you that this
new variant could pose a serious
disruption
to our progress and could make it more
difficult to move
to step four in june and i must stress
that we will do
whatever it takes to keep the public
safe
our surveillance and data gathering is
now so advanced
that if there was a danger of the nhs
coming under unsustainable pressure we
would
see the signs in the data very early on
and could react
in good time and that gives us
the confidence to continue moving
forwards
for now but i urge everyone
to exercise the greatest caution because
the choices we each make
in the coming days will have a material
effect
on the road ahead to those living in
bolton
and blackburn i'm very sorry that you're
once again
suffering uh from this virus and i know
how hard it has been for you having been
in a form of national or local lockdown
for longer than almost
anywhere else but now it's not more
vital than ever
that you play your part in stopping the
spread so
we won't be preventing businesses from
reopening
on monday but we will be asking you
to do your bit take the vaccine when you
can
get your free twice weekly
rapid tests and if you do test positive
you must self-isolate and we'll provide
financial support
to those on low incomes to help them do
so
as we move away from living our lives by
government rules and as we learn to live
with this virus then as i said on monday
we need to make our own
decisions about how best to protect
ourselves
and our loved ones informed by
the risks and for those living in bolton
and other affected areas
there is now a greater risk from this
new variant and so i urge you
to be extra cautious our our best chance
of suppressing this variant is to clamp
down on it
wherever it is and we'll be throwing
everything we can
at this task colonel russ miller
commander of the north west region
will be deployed to support local
leaders in managing
the response on the ground there will be
surge testing with mobile testing units
and the army will be on the streets
handing out tests
and there will be targeted new activity
in bolton and blackburn to accelerate
the vaccine take up amongst the eligible
cohorts including
longer opening hours at vaccination
sites
and to everybody else across the whole
country wherever you live
please get tested twice a week for free
and get a job if you're eligible
remember hands
face space and fresh air observe social
distancing from those
you don't know and if you're seeing
loved ones
think really carefully about the risk to
them especially if they haven't had that
second dose
or if it hasn't yet had time to take
full effect
i want us to trust people to be
responsible and
to do the right thing that's the way to
live with this virus
while protecting the nhs and restoring
our freedoms and it's very clear now
we're going to have to live with this
new variant
of the var of the virus as well for some
time so
let's work together and let's exercise
caution
and common sense thank you very much i'm
not going to ask chris to
to do the slides thank you prime
minister uh first slide please
the first slides are very familiar to
people watching these
uh briefings the first one is the number
of people testing positive for covert 19
in the uk and as you can see that has
been on a steady downward path and is
stable
in terms of the overall numbers at this
point in time next slide please
uh we're also seeing as you as people
will be aware a steady decrease
in the number of people in hospital with
covert 19
in the uk as this graph shows
next slide please and
the number of people who have died
following a coveted test
has also been steadily decreasing and
has remained
very low and remains low now so the most
recent seven day average
is seven to seven deaths per day
next slide please now we move on to just
the
newer information and i'm just going to
expand slightly on
on the data that's there so what we have
here is the weekly number of
sequence cases in england of the variant
uh the one 617.2
first detected in india and as you can
see
this is in it on a steady upward curve
this is an exponential growth at the
same time as
the b117 which is the one which is the
principle one circulating
uh in the uk at the moment has actually
been on a downward
slope so there is no doubt that this is
going up
and uh earlier this week we said that we
thought that we was as transmissible as
b117 and possibly
more so there is now confidence and sage
has looked at these data as have various
modeling groups
that this variant is more transmissible
than b117
now the question in practical terms over
the next uh
two to three weeks is is this uh
somewhat more transmissible than b117
or is this a lot more transmissible and
that will have implications
for uh the long-term uh prospects
of this epidemic and in the uk and
indeed the pandemic
uh internationally next slide please
uh and this is most clearly seen at the
moment in bolton although i
want to be clear that bolton is not the
only place that has this
variant it is quite widely seeded in a
number of parts
of england and indeed elsewhere in the
four nations of the united kingdom
and what we have here is rates in bolton
that were going down
but they've really now started to go up
uh very
significantly over the last
couple of weeks one important thing that
we're not seeing
is an increase at this point in time in
rates in people over
60 and that is very important because
that tends to correlate
very closely with people subsequently
going to hospital and some people
becoming very severely ill and sometimes
sadly dying
so this may be a delay or it may be that
the vaccine is helping to
protect those who are older and two are
vaccinated and that's an important part
of what the prime minister has just said
next slide please and if we look
at the greater manchester area
around the area where bolton is
as you can see there isn't at this point
in time a significant
uptick in the number of people being
admitted to hospital
but it's early days and i think this is
the point which we want to stress
is this is the first time we have been
completely confident in the increased
transmission
we now need to see what happens over the
next
two to three weeks next slide please
thank you very much indeed well thank
you very much chris
let's go to questions from the public uh
alexander in greater london
if the variance of concerns such as the
b1617 variant
increases in transmission to an extent
whereby it would result in major
hospitalization
how soon would you implement
restrictions and how many
hospitalizations would result in further
restrictions
thanks very much alexander well i think
the answer to that sort of
flows pretty much from what i said
earlier on and
uh that is that uh as soon as we saw
that there was a
a risk of a of a really serious uh
increase in hospitalizations on the
scale that would uh
that would risk overwhelming uh the nhs
in exponential
uh growth then of course we'd uh we
would implement
uh further restrictions immediately the
purpose of this of this press conference
is
is really to alert people uh to that
necessity
and to the extent of the risk that we
now see
in this indian variant but chris
anything you want to add to that
thank you um let's go to josh from corby
we have universities reopening next week
and the restrictions on social
gatherings soon to end in june
especially nightclubs when can the under
30s expect to receive the kobe vaccine
thank you uh chris i'm going to
ask for your view on the under 30s
thank you so the um as as i think
everyone knows what we're
doing in the uk is going in a very uh
steady uh but hopefully rapid and steady
uh progression in terms of vaccinations
starting with the most vulnerable people
so those are people
particularly of older age but also
pre-existing health conditions so
obviously some people
in their 30s either because they're
health or social care workers or because
they got pre-existing
health conditions have already been
vaccinated uh and people indeed
under under 30. but the the for the rest
of the population they're going in
a steady downward progression in terms
of age
and the reason for that is that the risk
is very strongly
uh correlated with age and so uh but the
the rate of uh vaccination uh is
continuing to be very
steady now uh we've actually got to the
point
where people are in their upper ages of
their 30s so
38 and 39 and this will steadily move
down
over the next weeks are being vaccinated
we hope to get all the way through
to everybody having their first vaccine
by the end of july that is the aim
additionally as the prime minister has
said uh there is for people
of all ages uh now an aim to accelerate
to some degree uh the point where people
get their second vaccination
and there are some advantages to having
a second vaccination later
uh and some data on that in fact came
out in the last uh couple of days
uh but uh what we do want to do is make
sure that people have their second
vaccines and that's why the prime
minister
talked about the fact we're shortening
the period the uh
from 12 weeks to eight weeks and this is
because we think that a
people who've got a second vaccine are
we'll have greater protection
not only against the original variants
but also against this new variant
so it is very important that people who
get their first vaccine
also go on to get their second vaccine
there's very clear evidence that people
are taking that up
that offer up uh very strongly across
the uk and indeed uh in bolton
uh and surrounding areas thanks very
much
chris and and josh fergus walsh of the
bbc
prime minister how likely do you think
it is that
the final unlocking will go ahead on the
21st of june and for professor witte
do you think that all those over 18
in hotspot areas should now have
immediate access
to a first dose of vaccine um
thanks ferguson and i know that
everybody will be asking that question
now
i think the the truth is that we at this
stage simply can't say for
for certain uh as things stand um uh
you know the you you've heard it uh
today that the numbers
uh of of infections even with the new
variant
uh remain low overall across the across
the country
uh even in in bolton where there's
there's been this uh
spike in the new variant we're not
seeing uh the significant new numbers of
hospitalizations it remains
uh broadly flat uh and the situation is
is different from uh last year in this
in this crucial sense that we
we are we are in the throes of an
extraordinary vaccine
rollout which everybody knows and and
understands uh so
uh we we've we've just got to
uh to wait and see you know those two
things the the extent to which
uh the um new variant may be
more transmissible and also the extent
to which
uh the vaccines have been able to cut
the link between infection and
hospitalization
and and death and
that we just need to see a little bit
more about that uh i'm afraid
uh fergus before we can be we can be
really say much more
at this at this stage uh we will
continue to proceed with
uh with caution uh but obviously we rule
nothing out and as soon as we can say
more about
uh stage four obviously uh we will
uh on the question you asked me um
there's been a debate about this but the
jcvi the joint committee on vaccination
immunization who
which brings together all the experts on
this has been very clear on this now the
fundamental issue
is that we have a finite supply at any
given moment in time a vaccine so if you
vaccinate one person by definition
you're not vaccinating another
now what do we we know certain things
about these vaccines we have
very high confidence that the vaccines
provide very substantial
protection against people dying and
people being having severe illness and
people being hospitalized
less protection against people having
more mild disease
and some protection but less still
against uh transmission
and the expectation is with new variants
that if you start to lose some vaccine
efficacy you lose it in the opposite
direction so in a sense
you first lose the very low uh
protection of people with having
asymptomatic or very mild disease
then you lose the protection against the
more severe disease and finally against
the really
most severe disease and people having
mortality now the reason i'm giving that
long preamble
is it's to explain why it is that the
thing we know this vaccine absolutely
can and should do
is to protect those who are most
vulnerable and that is very heavily
predicated
by age with this particular virus so
therefore
if we took people took a vaccine away
from
groups let's say in their late 30s and
transferred them to groups of people in
the who are 18 or
or 20 who are much lower risk of
uh severe disease the view of jcvi and i
think this is the majority view it's not
an absolute
the view of jcvi has clearly been this
would lead to a net
uh disadvantage overall so the sensible
thing to do is to prioritize the
vaccines to those who are most at risk
in all the places uh across the uk
because this the virus is a risk
absolutely everywhere
but there are very uh strong aims to try
and accelerate
uh and make easier vaccination in the
areas uh which are most affected by this
virus so it's not that uh
we're not trying to take uh the the
geographical spread of this new variant
the b617.2 into account we very much do
want to do that
thanks very much uh emily morgan itv
thanks prime minister uh given that the
easing of restrictions is still going to
go ahead on monday what would you say to
someone who's planning to travel to the
police because
they come back to you visit
family would you say that they should
still go and should they stay the night
thanks emily i'm very glad you asked
that because i i do think it's important
that
uh in respect of uh the areas where we
are seeing
uh the these uh spikes these higher
incidences of the
of the new variant given the caution
that
uh i think we have to exercise with this
new variant
the risk of extra transmissibility uh i
i would urge people
just to think twice about that that's
what we're saying uh
i think that we want people in those
areas to to recognize
uh that there is uh extra risk uh an
extra
uh disruption a threat of disruption to
uh progress caused by this new variant
and
and just to to exercise their discretion
and judgment in in a way i'm sure
that they have been uh throughout this
pandemic and and will continue to do so
uh uh i i hope very much
okay thank you uh sam coats of
uh of sky
hello prime minister these are your four
tests for moving to the next stage of
the
unlocking uh of the road map the fourth
very explicitly says that there can't be
variants of concern
changing the assessment given that cases
of the indian
variant have almost tripled over a week
how are you
passing or saying that you passed that
test how are you
giving a green light on that um and
what happens if uh and how can you only
say that uh you've passed these
because you're assessing them nationally
if you just looked at one region like
the north
west might you find that you actually
failed several of them and
would you un would you lock back down
regionally
um to chris whitty there's some data out
today suggesting
uh that the indian variant isn't really
rising in the over 45 a bit younger i
think that you were saying is that right
and to say patrick valance according to
public health england data at least 122
passengers arriving from delhi and
mumbai between late march and april
26 were carrying this variant
in retrospect do you think it was a
mistake not to close the border from
there sooner
uh well sam i'm gonna try and pick up
the question you you directed to patrick
since he's
uh unfortunately not here you probably
can't see that for some reason but uh
i will i will i will just say on the uh
on the on the borders issue
um the the what the
relevant committee was looking at uh was
the threat of variance of concern
uh coming from uh abroad and at that
stage
uh india was not identified as having a
vac a variant of concern so that was why
the decision was taken
pakistan for instance i think had uh i
think three times as much
uh of a uh of various of concern they
had in particular the
south african uh variant so that was the
that was the reason for uh
that decision but don't forget that
everybody coming
for gimme uh from india or indeed
anywhere else
uh had to uh face very very tough
quarantine
uh rules they had to bring that to
self i said that to produce their
passenger uh locator form
and and so on and but on the um
you know your fundamental question about
the the fourth criter the fourth test
um i i do think that
i just take go back to the the original
point
um the the we are concerned about
this variant uh and that's that's the
purpose and
we're serving notice that it we do think
i think
that it it certainly may cause
disruption
uh to our attempts to continue down the
road map
but it they don't at the moment change
the assessment about uh about step three
because if you look at the numbers as
i've said in
uh even in in bolton uh you're not
seeing
a a significant increase in
hospitalizations
and the overall numbers across the
country uh remain
as as we've heard repeatedly uh uh
low and and uh quite flat
so uh they're not changing the
assessment at present
but what we're saying is that the public
need to be aware of this
uh variant and particularly in areas
where it is
more prevalent and that's because of
these
uh questions about increased
transmissibility
and we just need a bit more time uh to
see how that
uh how that pans out and as i said
earlier on
whether it's at the higher end of
increased uh transmissibility
or or at the lower end if it's if it's
at the lower end uh then
uh i think uh you know we don't have
very much to worry about
uh but if it's at the higher end then
you know we will we will certainly have
to think about what
extra measures we need to take to
protect the public and
i want to be clear that we will react
fast we will react as soon as we can see
uh clear and unambiguous data about this
and we will do whatever it takes to
protect the people of this country
on the questions you asked me and i'm
actually going to pick up on the um the
four tests additionally
and if you think about the tests and
compare them to where we were this time
last week
virtually everything is the same
situation there is one very important
difference and that's the one i want to
concentrate on but just to
go through them vaccine deployment
program remains successful
vaccines reducing hospitalizations and
deaths very clear evidence they are
nothing has changed on that
infection rates not causing nhs pressure
you saw the data on that it's really
clear
and on the variance of concern excluding
uh the
uh b617.2
um really no change most of them are
relatively flat they're not a
they haven't gone away as a threat and
we you know but they are
staying relatively stable in terms of
the 617.2
variant one thing also remains the same
which is our current assessment of the
vaccine
likelihood of the vaccine being
effective remains what it was which we
think it will probably protect against
severe disease
and hospitalization we're not so
confident about
the degree to which it protects against
milder disease and transmission
and that's just we don't have the data
that would come with time the thing
which has changed
is the very clear view now i think if
everyone has looked at it
uh that this truck this is more
transmissible than the b117 and we
expect
over time this variant will overtake and
uh come to dominate in the uk
in the way that b117 took over and
indeed other variants have
taken over prior to that now as the
prime minister said
uh there are kind of some things that we
really want to look for
and the most important is is this a bit
more transmissible is there is this a
lot more transmissible if it's a lot
more transmissible
that would imply we could have a really
significant surge if it's a bit more
transmissible
that would imply we will have a bit more
pressure as a bit more of a race between
uh the vaccination program and the virus
but we are broadly in the same uh
territory so that's a really critical
question to which we do not yet have
the answer and then the other thing we
do not yet know
uh is in practice what the impact of the
vaccination program and this goes to
your second
question to me the question about people
over 45
we don't yet have a big enough number i
think to be confident about this
it could be that it is initially
circulating in younger ages
because that's what has always happened
previously you start off people mix more
and younger
the the initial circulation younger ages
and then it moves up the age range so
maybe it's just a delay
because of that or maybe it's a delay
because the vaccine
is actually providing a fire break a
barrier to reduce the
transmission up the ages into those who
are most vulnerable clearly the second
of those is
uh by far the more preferable but that
that we do not cannot say with
confidence at this point
and that's the reason we need to look
very clear carefully at this
this new variant see how much faster
it's growing than the old variant and
look at this issue about vaccines
in practice thanks very much uh samus to
the express
thank you prime minister um
if you are forced to take the drastic
decision to delay
june 21st realistically how long will
that delay be will it be a matter of
weeks or
months will we still get the great
british summer that we were promised
and to professor witte i'm given the
indian variant is spreading
mainly among young unvaccinated people
should those people in those groups
avoid taking advantages of the new
freedoms being introduced on monday such
as going to the pub
um well sam i i don't i'm free i really
can't
uh speculate about that in in in too
much detail
at this stage because as you've heard uh
earlier on
um there's just some things we we still
don't know about this new
new variant we just need a bit more time
i think a couple of weeks we will know
much much more than we than we do now
but i just want to say that you know i
know this has been a kind of
uh uh one of those press conferences
when uh everybody hears something
uh you know slightly disappointing or
slightly worrying
in the sense that there's a a new
variant that is a
significant concern for us does pose the
the real risk of uh of disruption to our
uh to our plans and i've got to be
absolutely
clear with with you about that but it is
also possible
sam that uh you know we could still be
on the right track uh we could still be
uh set fair and
you know the big difference between uh
this
discovery this new variant uh now and
and
and seeing that the the spike that we're
seeing in in bolton the the difference
between
uh uh our that phenomenon now
and uh is that and last last
christmas last december is of course
that we have the the vaccines and it's
we're in a we're in a very different
world now but as as chris says we need
to
be absolutely clear about
transmissibility
and about the effect of the of the
vaccines on this
on this new variant and we'll know a lot
more in in a couple of weeks
um hugo guy the of the eye
thank you uh prime minister and
professor witty what effect will the
decision to prioritize
uh second doses of the vaccine have on
the
rollout overall does this mean younger
people
will have to wait longer to get their
first dose
than they would have previously expected
or
is the government finally going to dip
into its stockpile of
more than 10 million doses that have
been delivered to the uk but not yet
administered
and perhaps speed out speed up the
overall pace of the rollout to
to match wales which as as you know is
now quite far ahead of
england scotland and northern ireland uh
in how many people
it's reached with at least one dose
crazy i can i can certainly take that i
mean uh
the reason the prioritization of the
second doses will not we think delay
um the situation the rollout for people
who are in the younger ages
and there are a number of reasons for
that but the uh the one of the key ones
uh is that the jcvi advice is that
except if rates went up very high and
we're not at that stage yet at this
point in time their primary
primary recommendation uh is that people
under the age of
uh 40 uh will be vaccinated in most
cases with
uh one of the uh messenger rna vaccines
fisa moderna
uh or whereas the revaccination program
is largely
uh at this point uh with az vaccines uh
so the expectation is this should not
lead to significant delays
you know we don't have that trade-off
which has been the uh issue elsewhere
it is though you know to reassure people
you know we are very um clear that we
still want to maintain a slightly longer
gap in terms of vaccination eight weeks
rather than the rather shorter periods
in some
uh some countries and that is because we
do think there are some advantages to
that so this is this is that we're doing
this relatively steadily that was the
advice from
jcpi and i think they've given some uh
information about that today
thank you very much alice the smile of
reuters
um prime minister do you think you might
one day look back on the decision to
ease restrictions across the whole
of england this monday as a big mistake
and with
international travel restarting should
brits realistically expect to get a
summer holiday
given the risk of importing new variants
as happened with this one
thanks uh thanks very much alistair
and uh on the i think that when
we're in a different position from uh
you know much of the past uh year 14
months 16 months or so
simply because we we were able to see so
much uh
so early and thanks to uh
the the the the testing that we're doing
thanks to the genomic sequencing
we're able to spot stuff really very
fast and so what we're trying to say at
this
uh press conference is that we do see uh
a real
uh risk of disruption in the uh in the
new variant
uh we think that on balance uh it's
right to
uh to proceed with the current plans
given the the very low numbers given the
uh the fact that uh hospitalizations are
are not rising but obviously uh we
remain
very very uh alive to
any change in the in the data and we
will react
accordingly and the same you know this i
think the same spirit of caution should
be applied to
uh to people who are thinking of of
traveling abroad
there's a very limited uh list uh as you
know
and we will certainly be making sure
that uh
you know people going to uh
traveling abroad will be subject to uh
all the all the tests and
uh and constraints that uh
that uh people would expect to prevent
the the virus being
being reimported that's why it's such a
a tiny list of
of countries and i don't uh expect that
we'll be adding to it
uh very rapidly and indeed we will be
maintaining
a very very tough uh border regime for
uh for the foreseeable future i imagine
it's just too early i'm afraid uh
alistair to talk about
uh exactly what the the summer will be
will be like
uh we we've seen this new variant
arrive uh we've been watching it for a
while we're now seeing
uh the risk that it's it's more
transmissible
than b117 we have to take account of
that we have to alert people
uh we have to give guidance and advice
to people in areas
uh where it's uh where it's been surging
even if the numbers
are currently low and as i said to
everybody we'll know more
in a couple of weeks we'll know a lot
more in a couple of weeks and we'll
we'll keep
everybody updated as as fast as we can
this doesn't mean that uh it's
impossible
uh that we'll be able to go ahead with
step four
uh i i don't think that's the case at
all but it does mean there is now
the risk of disruption uh and and delay
and delay to that ambition and we have
to be we have to be utterly
uh realistic about that and uh as i and
i want to stress again
you know we we take nothing off the
table as
a means of uh controlling this virus
and this variant and we will do whatever
it takes to to keep you all safe
thank you very much everybody thank you
well there we are then the prime
minister ending uh today's news
conference at downing street lasted
just over half an hour didn't it so
let's uh round up what he had to say uh
specifically talking about this
new indian variant a variant of concern
saying that we'll have to see if it is
significantly more transmissible than
previous ones which
that could lead to some hard choices uh
the race he said between the vaccination
program and the virus
could be he admitted about to become a
lot
tighter one thing he did state as fact
is that
he's going to accelerate uh second doses
uh
for over 50s and those clinically
vulnerable well listening to all that
and asking the questions for us
as our deputy political editor sam coats
as you can
see there so we know that this uh next
stage of unlocking will happen in a
couple of days on monday the 17th that
is going ahead as planned but serious
doubt it seems i mean
looking at these words here not
impossible that june the 21st will
happen but it looks to be
in doubt certainly now doesn't it and
the prime minister had
indicated just days ago that we were on
course for that unlocking then but
perhaps not the prime minister putting
the nation on notice that the next stage
after monday so the stage in june of
unlocking may not take place that's
right nick it was quite a dramatic uh
press conference some of those
uh phrases that uh we have
come to sort of dread talking about hard
choices that
uh that he's gonna have to make if it
turns out that the uh
indian varun is more transmissible uh
than we
thought the promise of effectively
delivering two parallel
uh stories today first of all he
confirmed formally that the
lock down lifting on monday was going to
go ahead so this is
uh the change that can see people go
into one another's house
houses go into restaurants and pubs and
meet each other inside which they
haven't been able
to do so all of that can take place in
england that's also
been confirmed uh for wales uh and large
parts of scotland
uh today although there are a couple of
areas of scotland uh where some
restrictions remain
in place uh so that will go ahead
despite
the emergence of this new variant of
concern and despite the the fourth
test in order to move through the road
map being
uh the fact that there's no uh variant
of concern that changes uh the
assessment so
green light to monday but the bulk of
the prime minister's
uh opening really given over to that
warning that there were tough decisions
ahead and if this progresses
uh if this new variant does go through
uh
and speed up and take off across the
country uh in the way uh that
we saw with the kent variant uh back in
december then that could mean
uh that the restriction lifting the uh
opening up
uh uh the complete unlocking that we
were expecting in june doesn't
take uh take place now there's an
absolutely critical
uh remark by chris witte in his answer
uh to my question
uh when i asked about the indian variant
and whether or not
we could continue unlocking and uh
whether or not there was little sign of
a rise in people over 45 getting it
because of the effect of the vaccine
he said the thing that has changed is
the very clear view
that this is more transmissible than the
kent variant
we expect uh with time that this variant
will
overtake and come to dominate in the uk
so the indian variant really has been an
issue in whitehall for the
best part of uh this week but it does
seem
as if within weeks it will be the
principal and dominant variant now boris
johnson very keen to stress
that there's no evidence of uh it being
additionally dangerous there's no
evidence
that it's more vaccine resistant than
than anything else but nevertheless this
is a concern so let's listen to
one of boris johnson's warnings as he
set out
the reasons for concern i have to level
with you that
this new variant could pose a serious
disruption
to our progress and could make it more
difficult to move
to step four in june and i must stress
that we will do
whatever it takes to keep the public
safe
our surveillance and data gathering is
now so advanced
that if there was a danger of the nhs
coming under unsustainable pressure we
would
see the signs in the data very early on
and could react
in good time and that gives us
the confidence to continue moving
forwards
for now so the prime minister promising
to level with us that phrase that almost
dread phrase that he used right at the
start of the pandemic during
the first lockdown now having to be
rolled out again because of the levels
of uncertainty
the specific decisions that we got today
they are going to double down on trying
to get the over 50s vaccinated speed up
the ability of people to get their
second jab
bring that forward from 12 weeks to
eight weeks they're going to allow some
over 45s and
to get their jabs as well more easily
and concentrate on that
it seems rather than vaccinating people
in their 20s and 30s
more quickly but how else the government
respond well i suspect we'll hear
about that in the days to come all right
so many thanks indeed
for watching over all that for us well
let's get some instant analysis the lib
dem
mp